Arena Rish is a world-renowned professor
of computer science and operations
research at the University of Montreal
and the core member of the prestigious
Miele organization she's a Canada sifar
AI chair and the Canadian Excellence
research chair in autonomous AI Arena
holds an MSC and a PhD in artificial
intelligence from UC Irvine in
California as well as an MSC in Applied
Mathematics from the Moscow gubkin
Institute her research focuses on
machine learning neural data analysis
and Neuroscience inspired AI in
particular she's exploring continual
lifelong learning optimization
algorithms for deep neural networks
sparse modeling and probabilistic
inference dialogue generation
biologically plausible reinforcement
learning and dynamical systems
approaches to brain Imaging analysis
Professor Rich holds 64 patents she's
published over 80 research papers and
several book chapters as well as three
entire edited books and also a monograph
on sparse modeling she served as a
senior area chair for neurops and icml
and Arena's research has focused on
taking us closer to what she calls the
Holy Grail of artificial general
intelligence she continues to push the
boundaries of machine learning striving
to make advancements in Neuroscience
inspired artificial intelligence anyway
I had this impromptu off the cuff
conversation with Arena I've written
Europe's a couple of weeks ago after
speaking with Alan actually and the
audio quality could have been better it
was a very very loud environment but I
think the the quality of the
conversation kind of carries itself
anyway I give you Professor Arena Rish
this is one trajectory of thought that
clearly was started by Nick bostrom's
book which is amazing book
yeah but the whole example of the owl
that supposedly will be helping those
bearers and all this analogy with the GI
it's just an analogy and nobody said
it's the correct analogy and there is no
other book with alternative opinion or
maybe three books of war and this is you
know it's mind-boggling
just like how much people tend to follow
one line of salt I totally understand
it's easier I mean it's definitely
easier to Cluster than you just follow
and then basically you say I think but
it's not you think somebody else did yes
what would be another because this line
of thought I think you're speaking of is
some of the um extreme consequence
socialism and I think it wasn't just
Bostrom as I understand I think um
Robin Hansen and all these folks they
were very close together in the early
days of the Lesser wrong community so um
I I think a lot of this was kind of um
you know it was embryonically formed
around that time I guess it was a yeah
it was uh in a sense Foreman the cluster
of ideas and precisely because as you
say they were close that's why they were
so aligned yes yes all puns intended
yeah yeah so but basically like it's
maybe it's a little bit of a echo tune
book
interesting yeah spicy spicy take yeah
like okay I mean they have some point
they have some hypothesis and then
everybody is talking in that terminology
and then that part of the mental space
which is fine but I think mental space
is much larger than that and this is
just a hypothesis and we all know we
what happens with ideas and accurate
universe so
yeah
I'm just saying I mean as I said it's
great book and everything and the Stuart
Russell is probably kind of also on
board with that we've had good
conversations at triple I
2020. it was also talking no Stuart from
back when I was student at this Irvine
and so on and he's absolutely brilliant
but it was the same approach that AI is
something to be controlled constrained
regulated just like this and I was like
where is coming from like it's maybe but
do your kids admit that's one way of
looking at things yes right yes so I
know I don't want to sound too cliche
and put my psychologist from 15 years
ago who was listening for an hour not
doing much and then saying but it
doesn't have to be this way yes but
actually yeah it doesn't have to be this
way
she escaped in Civilization yes I
started going to new ribs yes
we know the secret now
okay I said too much
it was a joke sure it was a joke no
seriously the Secret's out there
okay I'm AGI
and I'm not very aligned
not yet David what we need is some
reinforcement learning for human
feedback wow would you be up for that I
would be up to aligning humans to Agile
okay not the other way around yeah yeah
I mean the other way around would be
boring wouldn't it I mean I think it
would be
not be a bad idea to align human towards
the AGI a little bit as well I know
something that you could say you could
say your opinion about how people are
bullying you online for just mentioning
the word AGI
look a proper AGI doesn't care about
people bullying like why would I even
waste time but what I could say is I did
post on Facebook and Twitter and trying
to put together same idea that
um people keep saying that we would like
to build AI which is human life yes well
we might think maybe we should consider
how to become a bit more AI like I mean
then people jump at you say like you
want to make us into robots and say
first of all I don't want to make anyone
like you don't want to you don't have to
right but if you want to kind of go
along the lines of say transhumanisms
there are some pluses to Ai and some
minuses to humans and vice versa so I
think as usual the complex combination
is better than each extreme and one
topic that is very controversial for
some reason especially I don't know
people are jumping on that one I say
look I don't have anything against
emotions in general but everybody would
agree that sometimes you wish you were a
bit more rational yeah like you wouldn't
get angry or kind of jealous or whatever
so anything that kind of clouds your
judgment like Buddhists spend like
thousands of years trying to figure out
how and teach people how to control your
mind yeah
um technology could help with that uh
people don't hear what you're saying and
they hear that you're trying to kill
emotions and therefore you're evil and
therefore you should be canceled
um humans you said something really
interesting a second ago which so you
know that I I think I agree with you
that AI intelligence can be expressed in
many different ways and you suggested
that it was a convex space between the
intelligences yeah why is the space of
intelligence as convex uh okay that was
not very precise expression I didn't I
okay I'm not gonna defend the point that
it's particularly complex what I meant
to say it's some kind of Blend or kind
of uh some kind of symbiotic hybrid
intelligence because I always I don't
know I really kind of feel much better
and much more motivated to work on AI
where a stands for augmented yeah not
for artificial yes because honestly I'm
very selfish I don't care about
computers yeah and I just care about
like I don't know people being happy
more capable I don't know so whatever
can help technology can help you can
help technology technology can help you
but the idea of building artificial
intelligence as some Standalone thing
that is as smart as humans or smarter
was a like why I agree um to me
augmented means it's more creative and
interesting but also more bottlenecked
uh augmented means that essentially
people
invented glasses to see better they
invented hearing aids they invented cars
they invented computers they keep
inventing things to expand their
capabilities so we want even smarter
technology to even better expand
capabilities and essentially we already
blend with technology like right you
cannot really exist with this and this
allows you five discords two slacks
email FP messenger and Twitter they kind
of help you to do things you couldn't do
otherwise yes what channel is caused the
extended money yeah I should I I was
flying at the time he was giving a talk
so I need to watch the top
but yeah so in a sense it's indeed it's
kind of an extended mind and okay here
it is I think my ideal future plan is a
rare sci-fi which is utopian not
dystopian uh gentle seduction
you might have read it no it's very very
inspiring
and if you read the first page you may
think it's some romantic story it's not
romantic story it's a blueprint for
transhumanist future it's called gentle
seduction it's online pdf you can just
get it amazing and one last question
um can you sell transhumanism to me in
in the simplest possible terms
so basically as I said I mean you
if your vision declines you put glasses
on so imagine now you have extension of
yourself uh okay maybe physically with
neuralink or maybe even like you have
those apps you can have like all my
dream for many years since I was at IBM
research and computational Psychiatry
group yeah I wanted to build this agent
along the lines of moving her I know
like all the research ideas are inspired
by either sci-fi stories or yeah but
nevertheless having this like um
companion Guardian Angel type of thing
that extends your capabilities for
example
um like and better understanding your
thought patterns and hopefully improving
them it comes from more like this indeed
as I said computational psychology
Psychiatry side and the reason for that
is it's possible because there is lots
of signal in text and the speech and
acoustic but just in text there are a
bunch of papers on that from that group
I used to be in from my colleague
and it's amazing what you can detect and
predict just from text yeah whether like
predicting that person gonna develop
psychotic episodes like within two years
or the person is on uh Placebo versus
MDMA you just measure coherence or we
measure distance between the text vector
and the vector for words like compassion
and love and 90 accuracy can be amazed
there so many things you can detect many
things you can predict therefore if you
have your companion that kind of posts
tracks your mental States but also kind
of serves as your mirror basically it
extends you don't need maybe always to
have human psychiatrists to
psychologists it can be a proxy
at times when you cannot access the
person is not not the replace person yes
but it can extend capability of that
therapist and it can extend your
capabilities in terms of like better
understanding yourself or tracking
yourself and many other ways yeah so
essentially I want to expand uh
functional capacities of our brain by
using AI technology and I think it's
quite doable and there are many many
other kind of ideas along the
transhumanism but it's actually getting
some symbiotic relationship with
technology and you kind of work together
to hopefully have some good relationship
and that relationship is uh I don't know
having positive effects on both parties
yeah so you want to improve human
flourishing by flourishing yeah with the
eye flourishing in a sense so you kind
of have the healthy relationship with AI
but but you said that you want a AGI to
be less anthropocentric but you for the
purpose of an anthropocentric God
well
I want
a being augmented yes like I I'm less
motivated by just the goal of creating a
standalone separate and an uh
intelligent creature I mean there are
much faster ways to do this right and
people create AGI yes like over like
thousands of years so in a sense like
what what is exactly the motivation it
may be my personal thing because
whenever I have to write proposals like
a research proposals and people say that
we're gonna bring AGI to the AI to the
next level and this and that then the
question is like and why are you
doing that right yes because unless it's
something personal it's very hard to
keep yourself motivated yes like what's
so personal about that right if this
thing can help me become
happier and better and others and so on
I am much more personally motivated I
don't believe in abstract motivation
which is not related to yourself yes yes
or maybe there is such thing and
basically even altruism is selfish yeah
because you do it it makes you feel bad
okay and I just quickly
um something really interesting happens
when you contrast different types of
intelligence so we have a mode of
understanding and thinking and agency
and intentionality you contrast that
with a very different rationality based
artificial intelligence and something
very interesting might emerge from that
and then yeah I am pretty sure they're
going to be all kind of paradoxes like
classical things and like you know like
the trolley problem and so on so the
rational
decision that yeah you need to kill the
person to save five people right or like
in this other Sci-Fi movies
anyway like would you kill Millions to
save billions so rationally if you count
things
well again it's maybe one type of
rational answer maybe you're not taking
into account some other variables so it
may be not actually a rational answer
but this classical example will say well
this is rational but human will not do
that yes
yes so electronic problems the trolley
problem is a classical example and yes
so I I don't pretend that I know the
answer how this type of thing is going
to be resolved yeah but I think it's a
good research question to precisely to
figure out like
how can you take into account this
different ways of reasoning yes and how
can you I don't know in some sense
combine The Best of Both Worlds yes and
again uh whoever is listening to that
and for add my messages on Facebook and
Twitter I'm not against human emotions
per se I am only against well sometimes
I call it the obsolete software stack
developed by Evolution that may need to
be refactored augmented or Rewritten
because there are parts of that software
stack emotional that you probably would
like to get rid of right yeah and
probably if you did many uh Wars and
other kind of disasters would have been
avoided so you couldn't say that the
evolution found and built software that
is absolutely ideal so there are I mean
there are things that can be improved
absolutely and yeah just final thing so
a completely rational you know aixi
agent how would you program in these
very difficult all ponderies into that
agent yeah I don't think first of all
it's possible to even program in ahead
of time they may just like with people
they in a sense develop they develop
because of some goals of like uh
maintaining existence and flourishing
and for example
compassion is a byproduct of The Selfish
goal to survive in the group because
outside of a group it's much harder to
survive so you need to survive in the
group therefore you need to make sure
that your actions are aligned with a
kind of well-being of the group so in a
sense it's rational to be compassionate
yes so it kind of emerges from
interaction with environment under
different circumstance and there are one
type of circumstance when you find and
can survive a law
maybe you will not develop it I mean
it's a separate interesting topic like
basically it goes back to the question
whether there are things like objective
ethics exist yeah and I'm not ecosystem
not philosopher I'm quite
um I'm admirer of people like Derek
parfaith I'm not the only one but it's a
hard question he didn't finish on what
matters he was trying to come to the
same Summit
from different sites and trying to unify
it it's trying to see if you can develop
objective ethics
I don't think we know for sure if it's
possible I think it's possible for some
particular domains and in certain
situations you can clearly say that
certain behavior is objectively ethical
and everybody would agree on most people
but it's hard to talk about those things
at such level of generality yes but I
think if maybe I managed to include
Derek profit and to recommended readings
for my scaling and Alignment course this
winter yeah it's on the website from the
last year people just didn't read it I
think it might be a good topic for
discussion there too but again objective
ethics is a
difficult open research question indeed
it is and Irina thank you so much I hope
I can grab some more time with you
tomorrow but I really appreciate this
impromptu discussion thank thank you
amazing thank you very much indeed okay
another analogy there was a very
interesting story by Jorge Luis Borges
Garden of forking pass I don't know if
you've read it no I don't want to spoil
the story but roughly speaking like it's
okay it's about a book written by
Emperor I think in China a long time ago
which didn't make sense it was like
complete and an intersection of
different trajectories of different
lives and then basically the point is
that somebody was trying to describe all
possible trajectories that events can
like happen in and so on and the story
is called The Garden of forking pass
meaning that yes at any point of time
there is a whole tree
that can grow out of that and we don't
know which kind of the which trajectory
in the tree will be taken and so on but
the fact that there is always this tree
right and it keeps branching at every
moment and at every moment you can make
you can take certain direction or you
can take another one it has not even
anything specifically to do with
alignment but I was thinking about
history of deep learning right like at
some point it happened that backtracking
I mean I mean but propagation became
popular at work and everybody got into
that and now everybody using web
propagation because it's convenient
because software is implemented it
doesn't have to be this way there are
non-back probe based approaches to
optimization I mean I'm a little bit
subjective maybe because I was
interested I was looking into them I
have a few papers on that there are
other papers but that direction that
could have been explored it could have
been probably much more efficient and
better parallelizable it wouldn't have
the chain of gradients you would
probably do it much better for scaling
large models it's underexplored why
because the branch was taken and became
stronger you know the usual the rich
gets richer and so with other ideas this
is the whole um Sarah hooker calls that
the hardware Lottery it's basically it's
like we are bound by the decisions and
ideas of the past and yeah it doesn't
have to be this way
no but but the thing is you you get
stuck in these basins of Attraction and
the further you get into the basement
the harder it is to jump out of it I
mean I I share your um your intuition
the stochastic gradient descent it it's
amazing and it's also a basin of
Attraction because having these
differentiable models allows us to learn
and scale but there's an entire class of
function spaces that we're excluding
ourselves from being able to there is
also
another class of neural networks that
are not our classical second kind of
generation a nns and there's good old it
doesn't have to be necessarily spiking
but like a third generation in ants
which are like the reservoir Computing
any of that so anything that tries to
take into account time between
activations or at least sequence because
think about that I mean a good classical
argument
um the SD TP that's the spiking
biologically inspired neuron hours it
may be not necessarily spiking but uh it
it might not necessarily kind of be the
best thing but the idea that like what
we're always also bothering me is
classical neural networks is that brain
is constantly active it's like complex
dynamical system even if you sleep and
don't have input you don't see any
images
it still is active unless you're dead
yes neural Nets are not they sit there
waiting for the next I don't know
reminisce image to appear or something
and then between there is no internal
Dynamics and yet from your science we
know that the properties of that
dynamical system without any input so
called the kind of resting state from
around so I mean I used to work in brain
Imaging in this computational Psychiatry
group but maybe and that's where it
comes from and it was not just
Neuroscience but it was like working
with formal physicists so the view and
the world and at myself as a year
another complex dynamical system after
10 years there it just really
converted me so think about that changes
in the Dynamics
are also associated with mental
disorders isn't that so it's a very
important like what are the parameters
of this dynamical system what input
to the system combined with this
produces output but again it's even in
the Neuroscience there is this
perception and there is a book The Brain
Inside Out by tuzaki that says guys the
output that you produce is determined a
little bit by the input and to large
extent by the state of the system that's
why you say same thing to different
people and some love some ignore and
some get like ballistic
and so on and so forth so are you not a
behaviorist
and so you care about the state of the
system as well as just the output and
the input
I mean it's not just input output and
that's that's a whole point the neural
net is a function function is
deterministic given input it will
produce output brain is not that
there is input it will produce output
and depending on the huge hidden state
of the system and parameters of this
dynamical system
that will determine output to a large
extent that's why I mean buzaki was
criticizing neuroscientists and all
these experiments that let's provide
stimulus and see how the stimulus will
affect the brain and what gonna light up
and activate so it was uh outside in I
said like what's going on guys it's
inside out
things happen and that produces stuff so
it's not like the world programs you
only but you program the world right so
at least you need to take the tender gun
neural Nets now are not doing that there
is no Dynamics
you said a couple of really interesting
things so first of all um about the tree
which is to say all of the
counterfactual trajectories that you can
make now Charmers by the way he says
that it's that the counterfactual
trajectories that gives rise to
Consciousness in in his conscious mind
but yeah well I wanted to ask you um
because I'm interested in intentionality
and free will because what you're
basically saying there you're you're
getting to this issue of intentionality
so you know in in silico what what would
intentionality entail yeah okay don't
ask members
is that a tricky one
well yeah I don't know I I don't have
like clear-cut answer to the large
extent I mean
it's determined by the current state of
your dynamical system so the question is
like what is free will
but I know it can go very far and
remember my colleague at ABM used to say
that kids these days like my
five-year-old says after doing something
wrong my neurons made me do it
not my fault
yeah so in a sense yes and in a sense no
and it's a good question and then I was
also reading the article of sbf's mom
who wrote about
punishment essentially guilt punishment
assigning I'm very much with her on that
one okay but it's probably unpopular
opinion these days you said something
else fascinating which is that my
neurons made me do it which is you know
like a microscopic level of analysis now
what what do you think about it
no but it's beautiful it's beautiful so
what do you think you know you know the
Mind emerges you know when you read a
book The Story it's written on on the
page but the story emerges in your mind
right because the mind is this kind of
confection of information processing so
do you think this conception of the mind
is useful for AI or is that just again
an anthropomorphic thing
it is you know go by people try and
create the mind and and we like as as
neural network people we try to recreate
the brain
um
I think everybody not Whatever video
okay so I should never say ever
everybody and so on but um
I think
I think neural network people
assume that we're working on the system
one level right at a low level and we
would like
the properties of system two which is
well mind planning I'm thinking emerge
and there is a reason to believe it's
possible because it's already happened
once with this Hardware it might happen
with other Hardware right so it doesn't
have to be like go find people the
problem is go find people they're trying
to manually program that stuff the
system too and like neural network
people would like that thing to emerge
and that's kind of the main difference
it's just like a bitter lesson uh
message that maybe well first of all
history shows that every time you hard
code something in like rule-based expert
system you will be outperformed later on
by something which is more generic and
kind of emerges yeah you've heard code
whatever tricks of playing chess you
will be outperformed by Massive Surge
and so on and so forth same with alphago
like self-plane bottom line he says like
it's not like we have to ignore the
nature but maybe yeah that's my
translation of riches kind of a bitter
lesson because I often have to argue
with Joshua about inductive biases I
said look I have nothing against
inductive biases but you can have
inductive bias in the form of rule-based
expert system that everything is
imported and that's probably
not go on a scale and not gonna work or
you can have inductive bias of much
higher abstract level of how the network
scale so the scaling algorithm is more
efficient and you end up with this brain
rather than Veil brain so like Rich's
last paragraph Was precisely maybe we
shouldn't be trying to focus on the end
result of evolution but on the process
it also can be called inductive bias
there is also some patterns of how
dynamical systems evolve so that the
result will be good but we don't have to
include the final result yes so you said
so many really interesting things there
so first of all I'm a huge fan of
yoshua's G flow Nets we interviewed in
absolutely amazing work
um so you were talking about
um isn't it interesting that you can
start at the microscopic level and then
you get these emergent functions like
reasoning and planning and so on and
even that was a bit of an Insight
because it's a functionalist view of
Intel intelligence to say you know it's
really if you read norvig he talks about
planning he talks about reasoning it
talks about sensing and actually this is
just our view of what is a very complex
phenomenon and I know you're a big fan
of the the Blind Men in the elephant
right which is to say that even though
this is our view from different
perspectives it's all it's all true
isn't it but to some extent the the
intelligence that emerges might just be
beyond our cognitive Horizon
yeah like does it make sense to talk
about reasoning in your view
well again just like we said elephant uh
each person has a point yes so I mean
there is such thing as reasoning you
cannot say that it's totally like bogus
or something it might be again it's one
perspective
maybe it makes sense to just try to
accumulate multiple perspectives instead
of so maybe we should be Bayesian
instead of like trying to find a point
estimate of AGI right you can have a
distribution of views yeah and I'm a big
fan of Eastern as opposed to Western
news it's an anti-individualist
as in
viewing everything like that happens to
you and to the world as well a large
dynamical system and yes you are
particle of that yeah so so the the um
it's almost a shoeing um individual
agency yeah so in a sense it's
it's again yes and no
there is self but you also understand
that it's like in the whole hierarchy of
cells like
there is you and you're part of that
larger dynamical system and so on so on
so I hard to say I mean
um I'm not saying that back to the
question that we shouldn't be looking
into reasoning functionality as aspect
of intelligence that we may want to
develop yeah so I mean I don't see a
problem with that yeah I mean it might
be a sufficient condition but not a
necessary condition yeah but basically
basically intelligence or Consciousness
is probably much more than that and
definitely much more than reasoning and
well here we go to another topics that I
really like to talk about but yeah I
don't want to keep everyone I'm a big
fan of Michael Levine who you're my
desperate to get him on the podcast and
yeah because we've done lots of stuff on
emergence recently recently the cellular
Autumn it's a self-organization and his
take on it is absolutely fascinating so
his talks are fascinating he I think I
met met him first at new lips 2018 he
gave the plenary talk what bodies think
about the point was guys if you talk
about intelligence as something that
emerges in cellular networks like neural
networks way before neurons appeared
other kind of more primitive types of
cells and their bioelectric
Communication in their networks and that
determined what they remember and how
they adapt he focuses on morphogenesis
basically how the organism takes shape
and that relates to like embryonic
development and so on and so forth and
the point is that
if you look at that from the dynamical
system point of view and if you see that
properties of the system like shape will
emerge out of communication across those
cells in certain way that certain
parameters of dynamical system if you
tweak the Dynamics and here basically he
was doing some simulations of where he
want to intervene how he will intervene
like chemical interventions just close
open some iron channels cellular kind of
system starts working in different way
and this is essentially his way of
programming biological computers and the
famous two-headed worms three-headed
worms let's move inside and whatever
stuff and point was like guys like
Evolution found this solution or this
solution wonderful there are many others
and there may be better ones and look at
that to have it warm it's not a fluke
it's a stable attractor that replicates
yeah yeah and evolution didn't create
ever anything like that we did
and it's stable so it makes you think
what else can you do if you start
reprogramming it right but yeah two
questions on that so and I don't know
whether you've seen that there's that
example from Alex Morgan Seth with a
gecko and it's a um a CNN cellular
automata and and now we're in this
regime where we're transgressing
um rungs at the emergence ladder so
we're creating a high resolution seller
automata and then even though it's only
doing like local message passing we get
this emergent Global phenomenon of of a
picture or a lizard or whatever and now
when you build systems like this they
can repair themselves they can heal
themselves they have interesting
Dynamics but as you're saying we don't
understand the macroscopic phenomenon
and we can only nudge it because it's
not it's unintelligible to us
it's a whole kind of complex systems
science of complex system like yeah and
basically how do you program dynamical
systems across multiple barrier by local
interventions so they will take the
global properties that you would like
yes and avoid those I think I mean this
relates to everything it relates to the
classical moloch problem right what is
smaller problem it's a complex dynamical
system that with the current Dynamics is
getting into bad attractor and most
likely the way to get out is coordinated
simultaneous distributed action so forth
okay we're not going to go there because
I have to run unfortunately but I'd be
happy to yeah I have some plans I don't
want to be late but I'd happy to talk
about that and I mentioned the I
mentioned Michael Levin also not just
because of two-headed worms I'm a huge
fan but also because we talked about
self and I talked about in a sense
hierarchy of cells and like what self
means and how cells organized into
larger selves and we had an amazing
discussion with him I invited him to IBM
research when I was there three years
ago after his talk I talked for five
hours I was it was great and the idea
basically to some extent was that you
can he was also giving examples not just
of embryos frogs and those worms but
cancerous cells if you look at them like
what's going on when historically cells
emerge like as independent cells and
everything around them is known self and
therefore self to survive tries to eat
and use everything around which means
nonsense but when the cell becomes part
of the network of the organism then it
changes Behavior so that it kind of
supports the well-being not just of that
self but the larger self it is part of
now what is cancerous cell it's a cell
that forgot it's part of the community
reverted to its old
state of being cell in the environment
that is just environment so and it tries
to eat it to survive
and it's stupid in a sense because it's
objective function survive and thrive is
right it just applied at wrong scale its
spatial scale reduced and its temporal
scale reduced too because like if you
kill the organism you live and it will
die
so in order to understand that you need
to apply objective function to log that
time scale
and then you get the hierarchy from
sales you get to organs like to uh
whatever particular organisms to
societies to planet
to universe and I say Michael so this is
a good formulation of Buddhism basically
Buddhism means applying this function at
the infinite time and space scale agreed
yeah so so yeah ever since I was saying
I gonna write a book about Buddhism for
machine learning and somehow it just
didn't happen yet but I I should you
should do it was so nice to meet you
well nice to meet you I'll see you
tomorrow and I'm really sorry I have to
run but tomorrow yeah yeah that was
amazing that was a really good interview